hey Gary I got a very simple question
for you this is not the outfit to do it
in so one thing you're wrong brother is
yeah the right outfit on the first time
occasional rushes of motivation it's
like yes now I'm gonna do this but after
a few days that motivation goes away so
how do you get that constant stream of
motivation thanks a lot
you know this piggy booze you know this
piggy backs well off of the last
question you know my motivation comes
from a couple places one I love what I
do you know you may not love again back
to what you want especially seeing a lot
of the youngsters jumping in today's
show you may think that doing things is
the process needed to what you want
which is you want to be in Las Vegas
with 30 beautiful women around you and
like drinking champagne and going crazy
like I don't like that stuff no I don't
you know I don't like that stuff
I like the process and so you know to me
there's two things that drive me one I
love what I do for the billion time my
separating aspect from a lot of you I'm
keeping it real is I love working I love
putting in the work
I love the headaches I love HR
nightmares I love it I like it I like
the grind I like that I have a 6:30 call
today with an upset customer I like that
and so that's number one number two is
straight-up gratitude you want to have
real fuel I don't know what this meant I
just try to become Superman
if you want to real phew that was me
injecting gratitude you want real fuel
to to win be grateful
now you can't be grateful you can't
watch this video and be like oh great
Gary B he said I'm now grateful in me in
my personality is gratitude the
self-awareness that I was born in they
in the Soviet Union that the timing of
when I was born there was better than
when my dad was born they're better than
when my grandparents were born there
it created a scenario where this moment
in time where American Israel got
together and made a deal with the Soviet
Union and people were able to leave the
country and that's it I got really lucky
that what I'm great at is is really kind
of glamorized here entrepreneur
businessman whereas in Russia who knows
I'd probably be dead or a trillionaire
uh and so
I'm just grateful I'm grateful for the
greatest parents that one could ask for
I'm grateful for like amazing wife a lot
of you know unfortunately lost a lot of
my grandparents before I was even five
so I haven't had a lot of death and so
you know it's really like I don't even
have a gear that's like woe is me or too
bad first of all I also don't like
complaining I've made this bed like I
feel ill today I'm under the weather
right but I'm not like Oh what was like
watch this deer I don't know if I can
get in here people gonna like this let's
let's show something of fun to everybody
I don't know a rock talk to me can let
people see the schedule yeah I mean like
you know so schedule right like work out
at 6:30 and travel and meeting and
meeting and meeting and speak and call
and speak and tape the show right and
then call and then meeting and the
meeting and the meeting and the meeting
and if you're paying attention to ten
minutes ten minutes ten minutes five
minutes 15 minutes planning meeting call
call coffee meeting meeting meeting
meeting meeting meeting meeting meeting
meeting and today's a good day cuz it's
a Friday because I get to be done you
know by eight o'clock with dinner with
some friends but like when you go back
you know I mean the bottom line is I'm
in beating well this is Jets game but
I'm making my bed I'm making my bed I'm
going for it I'm hustling from 6 to 11
p.m. every day with every second
allocated there is no break there's no
there's no u2 salad and read read it or
watch YouTube that's that is not in my
game yes Steve that was for you you know
that isn't that is not in my game and so
because I've made my bed I'm surely not
gonna complain and be like uh I'm sick
today like I just you know no so that's
it I don't remember what I was answering
but that's what I think